but who do they fear most they fear this
Ron DeSantis guy and check out this ad
on Ron the scary Ron DeSantis
what governor Ron DeSantis is doing in
Florida is unimaginable and his latest
policy is a modern day book Burn
now the most cherished books of our time
can no longer be read by Florida
children why because Ron DeSantis has
censored them can you believe it
Classics like P is for penis and
peace and Moby's dick have been pulled
from the shelves of Florida Public
Schools does your second grader want to
read Charlotte's webcam well thanks to
Ron DeSantis that book has been banned
did you ever imagine a day would come
when children couldn't read titles like
Atlas pegged or catcher in the guy even
pitcher in the guy was taken from the
library
welcome to Ron DeSantis Florida a place
once known for being the most
erratically shaped state is now left
with zero erotic graphic novels for its
kindergarteners
and now in a Shameless Act of partisan
politics DeSantis is even going after
President Biden's beloved pop-up book
shower time
so we must act please vote Democrat
but in the meantime call the governor's
office and say you're doing me wrong
is another book we demand back on the
shelves with your help we'll put
indispensable titles like The Grapes of
ass to kill a cockingbird and hundreds
of others back onto our kids reading
lists
our children are the future and we
Florida Democrats will never stop
fighting for what turns us on
paid for by the global reading
opportunities Outreach movement
you see what we did there you guys
thought that was real you thought it was
real then it takes a turn and you go
what am I looking at but it's impossible
to know truth from satire These Days to
Kill a cockingbird by the way did you
see the author of that it was El Bobbitt
do you know who L Bob it is Lorena
Bobbitt so a little before yeah you're
Lorena Bobbitt was this woman like 20
years ago I guess she was in an abusive
relationship with her husband chopped
his Wang off old school now everyone's
chopping wangs off but she was doing it
before it was cool anyway uh look there
are some politicians that are standing
up against this stuff and obviously
DeSantis is the center of the center
[Music]
foreign